à l'hôtel transylvanie il y à du sang
neuf au revoir monsieur oui oui monsieur
mais je voudrais mais pourtant oui moi
aussi ça mais pas passable
alors oui le petit oui on a eu chaud
voire quelque part ne coupait pas mon
corps est ce que ça va tu savoures mal à
reprendre mon souffle de piquer sur un
trou et je suis d'accord
elle transylvanian 2 vraiment le centre
nerveux de l'histoire c'est voir un
enfant c'est un garçon la lignée des
préoccupations le pq et ben ils
s'appellent dennis il à mes cheveux
ouais pour vous et par contre il arrive
data beauté et surtout c'est un vampire
tu as vu ses cheveux et pourrait être
non c'est un dracula toute la question à
se poser autour de son éducation est ce
un vampire
est ce un enfant évidemment tombe au
père mon père voudrait absolument voir
pousser les canines ou sûr que c'est un
vampire papa je vérifie que ma part car
i oi on perd et jouée par kad merad
souffle souffle great à peine
plein de sang gicle de ton abdomen et un
dracula pour les enfants donc tant vécu
là qui fait peur mais qui n'est pas
méchante
oui ça va être le bien mon petit dennis
des choses qui font pas ok tu as ça dans
la peau c'est un grand-père gaga c'est
un grand père transformé il faut être le
plus dangereux le plus le plus terrible
personne pourra toucher le moindre
cheveu de son petit-fils montant des
personnes selon mon rôle c'est qu'elle
veut ça et ça les acteurs tout de suite
le bateau puis la musique la drôle de
tester leurs rejetons
tu présentes l'autre mon grand père a
pas trop remplacer michel reb records
nikon historique
voilà qui va devoir faire l'accent de de
transylvanie l'histoire
ok c'est chaud sur ta tête on dire les
lits chauds de ma grand mère
ah bah moi c'est un tas vieux type très
vieux
pas commode pas agréable au premier
abord mais si dans le fond sont de
braves gens et ensuite d'une flamme tape
et auch et boum croyez pas ça fera
sortir des canines d'un coup un dac
formidable ce que je sais du grand
michel parler vos valises n'est pas
pressé
attachez votre ceinture à fait ok tu te
coupe les ongles de l'énergie c'est
tellement drôle
moi j'avais déjà trouvé le premier
sublime est une fille hyper bien fichu
et je trouvais de seine pas ils veulent
toujours pas bon là je crois qu'il va
pas voler et maintenant grâce au film
j'ai bien sûr aussi voulait tranmere
enfants mayer par an elle va remettre en
selle au loto
c'est un gars de ma parole